aujourd'hui les capitalistes ils font
tous le siège de l'État pour que l'État
les sauve en leur donnant de l'argent ça
ça prouve que c'est une société qui va
mal et un règne qui est sans doute bien
près de finir
vous êtes ici ce soir pour nous annoncer
l'introduction en bourse de Lutte
Ouvrière
pas question en fait vous êtes ici pour
le Harlet Laguiller goodbye World Tour
la tournée mondiale d'adieu d'Arlette
Laguiller l'une des dernières chances de
l'avoir sur scène mesdames et messieurs
de nombreux meetings pendant la campagne
des européennes ce serait dans beaucoup
de villes de ce pays donc on verra sur
scène sur scène alors
est-ce que vous pensez que
l'effondrement du capitalisme est un
cadeau pour votre tournée d'adieu
Arlette
je ne dirai pas ça pour tous les
travailleurs qui sont en train d'être
mis à la porte et moi mon combat c'est
de faire justement que les travailleurs
ne fassent pas les frais des erreurs des
capitalistes de leur irresponsabilité et
les travailleurs n'y sont pour rien il y
a aucune raison qui fasse les frais
il y a un truc c'est que depuis toutes
ces années vous avez gardé les mêmes
idées la même coiffure les mêmes
vêtements
quand même non mais comment ça se fait
que vous aimez pas de changement ou quoi
j'aimerais bien changer la société
croyez pas je regarde quand même ce qui
se fait dans la mode
la semaine prochaine est une semaine
importante pour vous puisque mercredi
vous aurez 69 ans et vous êtes bien bien
conservé bien en forme
et je dis c'est la grande grève du 19
mars qui est une sorte de cadeau
d'anniversaire pour vous
je crois pas qu'elle a été faite pour ça
mais on l'a attendu parce que le 29
janvier était un vrai succès et je vais
même trouvé que c'était un peu long que
les syndicats n'auraient appellent que
le 19 mars parce que je crois que si on
veut faire reculer le patronat le
gouvernement aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
aille vers une grève générale
alors c'est 69 ans c'est une date quand
même non
je pense être plutôt les dizaines mais
on verra pour les 70 en tous les cas
vous êtes devenus une star énorme
vraiment
on va reprendre les choses au début vous
êtes né le 18 mars donc 1940 l'année de
l'assassinat de Trotsky au Mexique alors
si on était bouddhiste tibétain on
pourrait penser qu'il y a une espèce de
réincarnation comme ça qui s'est opérée
en vous
quel jour de la commune aussi
votre père Louis était ouvrier
plutôt un art et votre mère Suzanne
était secrétaire et catholique
pratiquante et vous avez fait votre
communion solennelle
quand on faisait suivre le catéchisme
j'y croyais pas voilà j'ai toujours été
une sceptique là-dessus il y a pas de
problème
d'accord vous étiez petit donc vous
aviez deux frères et vous étiez à 5 dans
un appartement assez minuscule une pièce
cuisine wc et un petit
couloirain comme on dit des Lilas dans
l'est de Paris et la vie était très
difficile pour vous parce que votre père
a été longuement au chômage votre mère a
été malade j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent
chez vous vous dites qu'en fin de mois
souvent le soir c'était café au lait
tartines quand même
c'était une situation effectivement que
j'ai connue alors vos parents étaient
pauvres il y avait peu de livres à la
maison mais quand même des livres de
Zola de Balzac d'Anatole France et puis
vous aviez un oncle qui vous offrait des
livres de la bibliothèque verte
la science le programme c'était plein de
choses première prise de conscience
politique à 14 ans avec la guerre
d'Algérie à 16 ans vous entrez comme
apprenti dactylo mécanographe au Crédit
Lyonnais vous y resterez jusqu'en l'an
2000 voilà alors en fait vous vouliez
être ainsi du tri si vous avez raté le
concours
une façon de faire des études à l'oeil
quoi c'est tout à 20 ans à l'âge où on
cherche une explication du monde vous la
trouvez dans Marx les lignes Trotsky et
en 68 au Crédit Lyonnais vous appelez à
la grève l'occupation d'entreprise déjà
on essaye d'occuper on va pas réussir ce
qui est terrible c'est que la nuit venue
vous êtes expulsé sous l'oeil complice
des syndicats et vous vous dites en fait
ce qui a manqué ce qui manque c'est un
c'est un parti communiste
révolutionnaire d'une certaine façon ça
a été aussi une chance parce que du coup
tous les gens qui étaient en grève bon
on s'est retrouvés aux côtés des
étudiants à aller sur le barricade
Quartier Latin à l'époque la nuit non
bah c'était sympa oui parce que on y
croyait on était jeune et on voulait que
ça change j'ai dormi à la Sorbonne parce
que je pouvais pas rentrer chez moi et
cetera bon voilà j'ai vécu tout ça
Arlette et les pétards non jamais jamais
alors ça j'ai jamais eu envie
de pétard
voilà donc en juin de la même année vous
participez à la Fondation de lutte
ouvrière vous devenez membre du bureau
politique et en 1974 à 34 ans l'Union
communiste internationalise vous
propulse candidate à la présidentielle
c'est absolument énorme parce qu'a
d'abord vous êtes une femme c'est la
première fois
c'est énorme première femme qui se
présente au présidentielle et ensuite
vous étiez dactylo au Crédit Lyonnais
quoi je veux dire c'était pas
de rester à sa place mais dans la
population dans les couches populaires
ça a été bien pris ma candidature vous
avez quand même fait 17,96 %
enfin 6 fois
vous avez été candidate six fois et
chaque fois battu au premier tour un peu
comme Henri Leconte à Roland-Garros
toujours est-il que en 40 ans de
d'action politique vous avez gardé le
même discours pourtant dans la vie on
change on évoluant on se contredit pas
vous quoi vous avez toujours été fidèle
à votre ligne vous savez la société je
trouve qu'elle va plutôt en s'aggravant
pour les couches populaires donc je vais
certainement pas renoncer à mes idées
élection après élection vous devenez une
figure nationale qu'on pourrait résumer
par un par un slogan grand-mère c'est
faire une bonne révolution j'espère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça vous fait quoi de voir que ce qui
fait vaciller le capitalisme c'est pas
vous mais le capitalisme lui-même oui le
problème c'est que il faut pas seulement
qui va s'il faudrait qu'il s'écroule et
ça pour s'écrouler il y aura besoin
d'une force révolutionnaire et qu'on
fasse une société qui soit plus basée
sur le profit mais sur la réalisation
des besoins de toute l'humanité vous
allez faire quoi de votre retraite les
travailleurs comptent sur moi et les
travailleuses comptent sur moi
aujourd'hui donc je vais pas arrêter de
militer même si c'est plus moi qui va
être anglaise
franchement vous avez pas envie de
penser à vous un peu de vous faire
plaisir
de temps en temps
quand même
dites-moi
vous regrettez pas de pas avoir une
enfant non honnêtement non non vous
savez c'est vraiment un problème qui ne
se pose plus donc voilà donc place
désormais à la relève Nathalie Arthaud
qu'on a trouvé dans un casting intitulé
à la recherche de la nouvelle Arlette
[Applaudissements]
ils font tous le siège de l'État pour
que l'État les sauvent leurs ordonnant
de l'argent ça ça prouve que c'est une
société qui va mal et un règne qui est
sans doute bien près de finir et on va
faire un quiz si Harley était présidente
qui s'appelle Arlette au pays des
merveilles
[Musique]
alors là si vous étiez présidente qui
dirigerait le pays
la population c'est-à-dire la grande
majorité finalement des salariés
ce qu'on appelle des conseils des
conseils dans les entreprises des
conseils dans les quartiers pour décider
démocratiquement d'un certain nombre de
choses parce que vous supprimeriez
l'argent vous ferez comme au Club Med
des boules à l'époque comment ça se
passerait là
ça on a nos propres vignettes est-ce que
ça serait comme ça je crois oui que le
vrai communisme comme je le conçois ça
serait une société où on produirait
suffisamment pour assurer la subsistance
de toute la planète les soins
l'éducation et où peu à peu oui sans
doute l'argent pour être disparaître
est-ce qu'il y aurait plusieurs partis
politiques
d'extrême droite j'espère que non parce
que franchement
est-ce que la devise du pays serait à
chacun selon ses besoins
oui de chacun selon ses moyens et à
chacun selon ses besoins de beaucoup il
fréquent
vous savez en réalité à part une toute
petite minorité qui soit c'est même plus
quoi faire de son fric qui veut le yacht
le plus grand la forêt de diamant la
plus grande etc globalement les gens ils
aspirent à avoir simplement de quoi
vivre d'éduquer correctement leurs
enfants de vivre le mieux possible
est-ce qu'on laisserait filer les
déficits on s'en foutrait comment je
crois qu'on concevrait la société d'une
toute autre façon dans une autre société
qui serait pas basée sur le profit sur
l'argent je crois que ce mot là il
existerait même pas le problème c'est la
mise en commun à l'échelle à la planète
de toutes les richesses pour qu'on en
finisse avec le chômage avec le
sous-développement avec la pauvreté la
misère dans le monde entier l'utopie
aujourd'hui cette pensée que le
capitalisme peut continuer comme ça moi
je vous dis ce système il va dans le mur
c'est génial et puis aujourd'hui
l'utopie c'est de penser que le
capitalisme peut continuer comme ça bon
ben voilà est-ce que on interdire le
Coca-Cola on est moi j'aime bien le
Coca-Cola je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce qui était extraordinaire c'est
que c'est 35 heures qu'on a qualifié
d'archaïsme la française non mais voilà
mais aujourd'hui ça va sauver le
capitalisme en tout cas ça permet pour
le moment effectivement dans les
entreprises où il y a du chômage partiel
que la perte de salaire soit moins
importante et même si ça va être porté
paraît-il à 75% au lieu de 60% de
compensation et dans des familles où le
vin du mois on s'est déjà pu comment on
va terminer le mois et ben c'est très
dur donc il faut que les travailleurs
quand ils sont au chômage partiel ils
sont à payer à 100%. merci de l'avoir
reconnu le gouvernement a apporté la
compensation sur le chômage partiel de
60 en fait à plus de 75 on va être
pratiquement 80%. c'est jamais assez ça
quand même
soit baissé même de 25 ou 20% mais non à
la mer pour les actionnaires je suis
désolé
toutes les entreprises qui font du
chômage partiel ou qui font des
licenciements ont versé des dividendes
importants à leurs actionnaires faut
arrêter toujours désigner 4 entreprises
symboliques d'accord mais il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de petites et moyennes
entreprises en France qui n'ont ni
actionnaires ni les capitaux total ni
les bénéfices à cela quand on dit dans
les autres pays s'inspirent oui ils s'en
inspire sauf que et lui insulté c'est
que par exemple le Royaume-Uni en
allemand par exemple ouais mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ils disent on
passe de 40 heures par exemple à 32
heures mais avec une baisse de salaire
de 20% oui mais en France on a dit que
en passant au 35 heures en baissé par
les salaires ont touché pas au salaire
donc c'est pas la même chose je croyais
que Martine Aubry avait enfin réussi un
truc à part ces fringues évidemment
toujours les fringues des femmes
c'est quoi
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu